[Music]
hi
i'm lucy dagostino mcgowan and i'm
excited to talk to you about designing
randomized studies using shiny
you can find me on twitter at lucy
lucystats
and you can find these slides at
lucymcgowan.com
talk so the work i'm going to be talking
about today was done in collaboration
with students in my data science lab at
wake forest university
in particular jonathan trattner and nuri
park
and you can find some of our other
projects at dmds.lucymcgowan.com
okay so i'm going to show you four ways
we can leverage the power of shiny to
help streamline our randomized
study design via informed consent
randomization
collecting demographics and
incorporating learnr modules
so informed consent informed consent is
a common process when involving
human subjects in a trial often you hand
people
a piece of paper and they either say
that they agree to be in a study or they
don't
and so instead of that we can actually
have the entire process completed online
from the comfort of your participants
browsers
and so we're basically going to leverage
shiny such that if the user consents
they're sent to the study and if they
don't then they're sent back to the home
page
and so in shiny we often work with two
components the user interface
uh what the user sees and the server
what runs behind the scenes in r
and so here's some code for the user
interface to be able to incorporate
the consent here and so first you can
incorporate the consent
text via an html document for example
and then you can use an action button
function to create a nice action button
that will either send the participant to
the study if they agree
or back to the home page if not
so on the server side we need to check
whether the user clicked yes or no
and then send them somewhere accordingly
and so this function will check if the
user clicked yes
and if they did it's going to open a new
window and send them to the link
i'm doing this using render ui so i need
to make sure to update the user
interface
with that ui output so that this
actually works
and so that's what this is doing here
this ui output and then open study was
the
id that i gave that that output in the
server
so now that will actually send them to
the link
so one of the coolest things about using
shiny for this is that it gives you the
power of
r uh from the web browser so we can
actually randomize participants at the
time of consent
so it basically really streamlines that
process
so we just need to update the server a
little bit to do that
and so essentially what i've done here
is i've added a coin flip to determine
which group the participant should be in
and then they're sent to a different
link accordingly
so we're developing a package in r that
does this and a few other neat features
like generates users ids
saves a randomization list allows for
unique links for users etc
it's very much under development but you
can find it on github at jd chat
task design r
okay so now that we've randomized folks
let's collect some demographics
so we have another package called shiny
surveys uh that can help with this and
this one actually is almost ready for
prime time so i encourage you to try it
uh you can install it from github at jd
chat
shiny surveys
and so basically what this package
allows you to do is it lets you pass a
data frame with questions
options uh input types dependencies etc
and a nice shiny questionnaire is going
to be generated for you that can then be
incorporated in your application
and so in r it's as easy as just loading
the package
and then using the survey output
function in the user interface
passing the data frame with your
questions in it and so here my data
frame is called
d and then using render survey
in the server function and this will
you also will pass it that same data
frame and this will automatically
generate a nice survey
it'll look something like this where it
has the questions
as well as uh the the different places
to input
you can have required questions with
those little stars
you can also have dependencies for
example if you answer a certain way then
new questions can pop up accordingly
so finally all this can be incorporated
in commonly used shiny tools like learn
r modules
so for example learn our modules can
record all of the user's input data
which can be great for a study
and you can stick the user ids generated
from the task designer package in here
and then you can save this data with a
unique id that can be linked to the
demographic data for later analysis
so that's all you can find me at
lucystats
on twitter thank you so much